the tides of life are
an endless cycle merging man
and god as one
[Music]
you
scooby-doo
all right what's up everyone i'm here
with tony lane casterly we are at brain
mine at stanford we got a chance to hang
out together it's been a while since we
featured tony on our show
how long has it been it's been like six
months yeah not six maybe
five four five yeah four or five okay
it's been a little while so
first thing that we started talking
about
was about light dark about
masculine feminine about
interdimensionality
just about all these different forces
that exist that
it's difficult to put a tangible grasp
on so
let's keep diving into what we were
talking about because it's been so
fascinating
sure yeah so we were talking about i
mean this conversation really started
with the idea of what is the human
relationship
to consciousness in the perspective of
time you were saying i feel
like white forces are coming into the
world
right and they're just like we're we're
conquering we're conquering that age of
darkness
and my follow-up to that was have you
ever heard of the hindu concept
of time as a yuga so the yuga is
basically break
time up into four different dimensions
starting with the satya yuga and ending
with the kaliyuga and the difference
between hindu time
and our spatial relationship to time is
like one line
you know time by the way we'll get into
time because time isn't a line
really or a circle time is a dot time is
a dot and it's happening all at once
it's just that different dimensions of
consciousness
perceive time differently based on the
amount of consciousness
that that subjective consciousness is
perceiving the holistic consciousness
width
but okay okay this is this is getting
into we need to break down i'm gonna
break this down
okay all right unpack unpack so all
right so we have
time as a dot time all happening at once
at the same time
and when you kind of made this point
earlier we think
in a very earth-centric way yeah and so
because of that we have this sort of
timeline of time
but is the universe not 13.8 billion
years old
well not exactly so i mean when we but
we're when you say the universe right
we have no idea the spectrum of the
known universe
there might not even be a starting or a
stopping point
right in this it might not be that um
something has to be created for it to
exist
right so there are some there are some
questions we just simply don't know
the answer to yet and if you look at
eastern i don't know if you know what a
vajraja is
is this little symbol it looks kind of
like a barbell
except it's very small in the center and
it has these two big orbs on the side so
it looks kind of like this
and the vajraja actually symbolizes in
eastern culture the nature of our
relationship to the universe
that the universe kind of has this point
and it expands
and then it contracts and then it peters
down
and then it begins to expand again and
contract again
and that's the nature of the whole we're
going to the heat death
or the cold death going towards some
death
is potentially inaccurate that it might
just go down to a bottleneck and
come back up as another birth and yeah
then the multi-verses as well and then
interdimensionality
wherever your spirit or your soul lives
it's just living in this physical form
right now is that right
well the egyptians have no word for
death so
they actually call if you read like i
don't know if you've read the tibetan
book of the dead or the egyptian book of
the dead
they don't actually say dying they call
it walking
like your soul is walking from one life
to another and if you look at
buddhists like if you look at buddhist
literature when they talk about i
actually asked this question of
well what happens to life like if a soul
decides it doesn't want to come back as
a human
right if if a soul leaves its body and
it just
goes it just becomes energy what happens
to that energy and the response that i
received was that
that energy goes back to all living
things if a soul
fully transcends its body that energy
goes back to all living things so it's
the idea of there's this story called
the egg and
the soul transcends its body yes so you
have to go through a transition process
in order to attain this walking
well so there's a difference between
walking and a soul
like transcending its body to the extent
that it becomes other forms of energy
so if your soul is walking then it means
your soul has the intention to come back
and experience the physical realm again
like as a bodhisattva
but if your soul just becomes a form of
energy then that energy goes back to all
forms of life so you might imagine
that their your soul is potentially made
up of every other soul that exists on
earth because every time
someone touches you they leave an
imprint it's as if imagine
every time you have an exchange with
someone a really powerful meaningful
deep exchange of energy
that they take a piece of their
fingerprint and they leave it on you
and that fingerprint transcends with you
through the dimension of time because
you are you are molded in my mind
yeah and also in my physical body and
in the in my physical body and in the
energy that inhabits this
this body the energy that exists outside
of what can be measured in physical form
non-physical
matter there is an entire dimension of
non-physical matter that exists in the
world of lucid dreaming and obese that
we have yet to understand or quantify
through science and that's only one
dimension
of our quantum consciousness right
consciousness is not just confined
to the human form there's so many layers
of this but from a basic standpoint
if you have a lucid dream if you have an
out-of-body experience
you still exist right but do you exist
physically
no you exist as a form of energy and
that energy is not necessarily it's
still
attached to your body through what we
call like the string of light
right ring of light yeah okay so it
hasn't fully if you ever
see your body in an out of body
experience a lot of people will describe
this phenomenon called the string
and it's a string that is tethering you
can actually see this in greek mythology
do you does the string get cut when yeah
okay i was gonna say what did the faiths
do
have you ever seen hercules the disney
movie yeah you know how there are those
three ladies
and they all have the one eyeball that
they use and they share and the fates
all use their one eyeball to see in
different ways
and then whenever a soul goes to the
underworld
the fates pull a string and one of them
cuts it
and that is when the soul leaves the
body
right so and there's a big difference
between having that thread cut
and actually deciding making the
conscious decision
to to leap this is why books like the
tibetan book of the dead are actually
instruction manuals
for the soul to move through the
dimension
of actually leaving your physical body
there's a ton of literature on this
it's just that we we haven't actually
adopted this in popular western science
because
we don't have the tools to measure
phenomenons that we understand
to be inherently true as human beings we
are about to augment the scientific
method
and get us to the next iteration of
yeah being able to understand this this
is
i i stopped using the word esoteric
because
i think when you label it as more
difficult to understand it draws people
maybe away from it so rather i maybe
we're
maybe starting to use something more
like just
it's it's divine and it's and it
requires
practice of communicating like this and
feeling like this
in order for it to become more true and
embodied
it's like embodied wisdom but it's but
it's got lost
over time due to focus on
economics and politics and well and
really
our it actually has to do as well with
our earth's
relationship to the cosmos right so we
were talking about the yugos earlier and
we have the satya yuga which is like the
gold mage it's the garden of eden it's
described as the period of time where
gods and goddesses
reign when was that so the satya yuga is
actually represented as the period of
time we're entering into from 2012 to
2018
is the transition window into the satya
yuga from the kali yuga
and the kali yuga is the age of
degradation basically it's the golden
calf the worshipping of false idols
degradation materialism uh the loss
of that no no no we just loved it you
just left it so the mayan prophecy if
you look at the mayan calendar that
information like how do we how do we
know that how did they know that this is
thousands of years old
ancient wisdom i mean really ancient
wisdom and and
you know languages that in so many ways
i call this the forgotten period of
history
because if we knew it was this good at
one point in human history
if we would have known it had once been
this good i don't think we'd spend our
time
getting lost in all that darkness yeah
right but we again have not had the
tools to transcend our
earth's relationship to the cosmos or
the center of energy in the universe and
so we're
locked into this cycle right whether you
know consciously or unconsciously
for for some or others and so the mayan
calendar ends in 2012
not because it was meant to represent
you know this like the world will end
but that this is the end of that
particular
age the part of the sun
orbiting the center of the milky way you
know i don't
i don't want to say the milky way
because i think that that
is a really minut
like it's a known thing the milky way is
a milky way
orbiting something else or getting
pushed away from all the other galaxies
that
might minus andromeda just that the
energies of the
universe i don't know i don't know
exactly how do they
know this information well so 2012 2018
is
yes the difference between eastern
marshall mcluhan even talks about this
the reversal of the eastern and western
mentality and the western mentality is
very much about
measurement logic rigor focus like the
idea of the south and the eastern
mentality is very much about the
intuitive perspective and the
understanding of the collective this is
why if you even look at mandarin chinese
symbols
most of these symbols are intuitive
symbols and one little inflection
can change the whole contextual
relationship
to a word and so we're moving back
into this eastern understanding is
represented by ideas like buddhism
hinduism
where our concept of our relationship to
consciousness is actually shifting
right and so uh yeah i think that's
really and
like i was saying earlier you know we
have as when we think about our earth
what we're thinking about is how do we
measure our earth and the known things
even what you were just saying like to
the milky way like can we measure our
earth and then its relationship to the
sun and is that the center of energy in
the universe or are we going to measure
something else and is that the center of
energy but it's all based on
our logical understanding of what we can
measure and perceive
factually rather than the intuitive
understanding
the sensing of something and the feeling
of something and the feeling of
something
being understood so inherently as a
collective
that the feeling of something becomes
unknown yeah right and so it's really
just a reversal of those mentalities
that informs our relationship
to the structures of logic we use to
even formulate our scientific discovery
what would be something that we would
collectively
feel in order to gain some intuition
about
life and existence so this is an
interesting question because we're in
this transition period where we have a
lot of these still really western
methods
being brought into this more
collectivist mentality like if we look
at the evolution of whether it's
singularity theory neural nets um you
know harvard
and other institutions have done studies
on brain to brain communication
right so we're seeing these tools of
measurements now being used
to transition into this new way of
thinking
and into being if you um
if you choose to view your relationship
to time as rather than the earth as
being on a
its own discrete timeline as the earth
being a very minute portion of an entire
cosmology that exists
outside of us it's really more about
understanding
our place in the cosmos from the
perspective of the cosmos than it is
about understanding our place on the
earth in relation to what is known and
measured
yeah okay so there's there's that one so
that that that's a very important one
it's kind of it's it's taking the
the cosmic perspective that is not
earth-centric
and it's not three-dimensional centric
okay so there's that and then there's
this
whatever is going on between realms or
dimensions that we don't understand what
these forces are
some people apparently understand them
better they
figured out how to intuitively feel and
tap into
these places that are somehow
earth is a is is earth a place of free
will
do you think so so i the line between
uh free will and determinism
is the same explanation i use i was
actually asked a question on the
panel i was speaking on yesterday and
the panel was
social good uses for blockchain
technology and we had the most amazing
amazing moderator that i've actually
ever worked with
and his initial question was
you know talking about blockchain and
social good rather than saying let's
talk about blockchain in relation to
social good it was eric van der kleisch
and his relationship to rather than
saying you know what are some social
good use cases he said what is good
right and so when we talk about free
will and determinism
you can't really have one without the
other
and so it's really that you can't have
bad without something to measure it
against
so you can't have what is determined
without a measurement of our free will
in interacting with the spectrum of what
could be determined it's really like
uh i'm trying to think of the best
expert it's like a mycelia
right like a mushroom and the way that
you watch or
understand something to grow like there
is a set pattern underneath that this
will become a mushroom right but if you
really peer into the way in which
something evolves like the pattern
underneath all of this is so is so
unbelievably dynamic right
i think i was talking about mycelia when
my friend called me but it's kind of
like saying you know there are a million
different ways for life to evolve
and that on even this planet earth since
we've been alive
there could have been one action that
happens
when dinosaurs were here and that could
have affected the evolution of
hundreds of different kinds of species
whatever occurred in the cosmos that
sent that asteroid to impact earth
whatever occurred it ended up enabling
humans to
be born i think so
so what could that be what about now now
we have
all this existential threat mitigation
you're counting right now
so i wrote this haiku about the meaning
of life as relation
in in relation to what you just said
about existence and the asteroid
and it is the tides of life
the tides of life are an
endless cycle merging man
and god as one that's pretty good i like
that one
that's a really good one yeah
and do you think that's happening on
other planets orbiting stars
so that's an unanswered question uh
that's an unanswered question and i i
think that
there are certain questions that it's
kind of like
why would you want to ruin the fun there
are certain questions
that you cannot know the answer to that
question until you reach the state at
which that question can be answered
so in in relation to kind of this free
will and determinism and evolution it's
as though there are certain forms of
knowledge that cannot be known
until an individual through their will
has reached a space of knowing that
allows that information to be able to be
understood
it's as if you're a child and you are
three years old and you have someone
looking at you asking you
to read hegel and you're like whoa
i'm three like what's up with like
sesame street over here
like i'm having a good time with big
bird and elmo and
oscar too so we're unable to comprehend
right now because we don't have the
tools needed to go and investigate and
figure it out
okay well if the purpose is
this continuous emerging of of
human with with god then higher states
of consciousness higher states of
consciousness
yeah yeah humans with higher states of
consciousness then
have we not how do we know we haven't
already reached
that point and now you're just
because we exist well yeah but you could
yeah but you don't know if you're
you don't know if you're existing in a
base reality or not right now but we
exist
and because we exist if we if if there
was nothing left to learn and there was
nowhere to evolve and there was nowhere
to go
um every form of energy would transcend
into a state of bliss that would say
we're done like the puzzle's been we've
completed the puzzle here
isn't that what it's going to feel like
when we eradicate suffering that like oh
cool the puzzle's complete now people
don't have sickness from drinking
contaminated water they have roofs over
their heads
isn't that going to be a good feeling
why do we have to have this bad of
of suffering in order to know what it
feels like to not have suffering
can we just not have suffering and still
understand suffering
just just through other experiences that
teach us about it
well i don't know if that's the point
but that is one of the most important
lessons you need to learn
to evolve into a higher state of
consciousness is the idea of
seeing yourself outside of yourself and
through the ability to see yourself
interdimensionally your understanding
that your relationship
to the idea of suffering is you
embodying illusion
and when you're able to dispel the
nature of your relationship to
the illusion of existence then you're
able to understand more about the true
untouched nature of reality which is
beyond
that suffering let's see if i can break
this down so so if
i can unpack properly to your liking
so so so if if i have if i don't have
access to clean water
and i get upset because i don't have
access to clean water and i'm
thirsty and i'm getting sick from
drinking contaminated water
that that suffering is a
choice because i'm not transcending to a
god-like
level and a lot of what we need to do is
figure out how to transcend to that
god-like
level not exactly like
sort of yes but the like idea of the
idea of a god-like level and the we
understood
our inter-dimensional being capacities
and capabilities
then we wouldn't be stuck worrying about
this water we'd be like
even if i die from drinking this
contaminated water i'm an
intergalactic interdimensional being and
it doesn't matter that i die when i'm
10 or about 40 or 100. and there are
actually i mean if you dig really deeply
into
these gurus and monks there are
people i have actually worked in
specific
um with a priestess her name is alanya
forsberg
uh she's norwegian and i have i have
physically
seen her do
acts of consciousness uh that i can only
describe as
extraordinary and metaphysical seeing
seeing gurus
take sickness out of people's bodies or
being able to drink something
contaminated without getting sick being
able to pull
a vehicle with their hair that is full
of tons of bricks right there are
feats that are possible that are
unexplainable by a normal state of
consciousness that are attainable to us
as human beings and so there's only but
there's really that really makes me feel
like i know nothing and i'm just
leveraging so little of my potential the
only thing we'll ever
know is that we'll always be learning
because
the what we really know at the end of
the day is nothing and when you realize
you know nothing then you can deal with
everything as it comes
yeah because it's not about the knowing
but it's about the balance between
presence and our existence through time
presence
and our existence through time but
time's happening all at once
so time is a dot right like it's the
idea that
uh time is not happening
in either or both an eastern
and western mentality time is a dot
it's happening all at once and in many
different dimensions
the same story i was talking about
earlier called the egg
a man passes and talks to god and
god tells man it's a very short story
god tells this person that they're going
to be sent back in time to
4 a.d to live as a
peasant in uh a peasant farmer in china
as a female this person says what
and then god says yeah i mean you're
everyone
you're hitler and you're every person
that he persecuted
your jesus and your every person that he
saved you're also the people that killed
him
right and so time is happening all at
once and our ability
to see time or to see time in a
different dimension than we perceive
through physical existence is something
that i have found
to be more accessible to people through
dreams like if you look at indigenous
nations you have people that do
these that have these visions visions
that are actually
understood to exist visions colloquially
that are understood to actually happen
in the real world
and there are many prophecies and there
are many visions that have been
seen through these dreams and through
the human relationship to consciousness
beyond the dimension of what exists
merely subjectively for us
and so i find that lucid dreaming this
lucid dreaming and these out of body
experiences are a way for us to exist
still within the state of our own
consciousness
while also transcending the nature of
the present physical reality that exists
around us
and in doing that we begin to receive
information
in a different dimensional capacity and
when we receive that information we
begin to learn
different lessons many of which are
still
fortunately actually unmeasurable
we as a human race in some ways or not
uh
it's like even if you evolve very far
you gotta wait for everyone else to
catch up
you know it doesn't work that you evolve
and then everyone else evolves any
profit that's ever lived could tell you
that
we have we're playing this endless game
of ketchup with the rest of the world
but all of those people
are a part of us too
is that potentially also
has something to do with maybe that
that feeling of of taking on
other people's emotional state or maybe
when we
that that we are part of them in that
moment you were talking about it earlier
like you have a space in my body in my
mind because you are you and we've hung
out this many times etc
let's uh let's let's wrap up just uh
this is this is very fascinating there's
just
there's something about this that
i find to be a reoccurring thing now
in my life yeah more so than ever before
and i think carrying a
perspective of open-mindedness is very
important
for sure and that
can lead us to having more of these
conversations
and a lot of it is the open-mindedness
but also it's i think i would say
it's almost the open-mindedness of the
other person as well
because there's open-mindedness on my
end of asking you questions and being
open to listening and learning
and there's the open-minded of the other
person when i'm asking these questions
to people that are
that are not building things or talking
about things that are
very tangible in a sense but that are a
little bit
more like interdimensional and spiritual
and stuff
so i think it's open mindedness is on
their end as well in terms of just
being okay with admitting that what they
are
saying might not be the 100
correct truth and nothing is that's kind
of the beauty of life is that there
is no 100 percent correct
truth there are things that are you
breathing oxygen right now you
understand right there are things that
we can understand
okay right but they're all subjective
things actually the oxygen example is a
great one
what about your heart beating so someone
used the example oxygen and gravity are
two of my favorites
right because someone says oh you're
breathing oxygen right now so that must
mean you're alive or you exist or you're
here i said well
you know oxygen isn't an absolute
neither is gravity
we just go a few bits outside the earth
yeah we have neither oxygen nor yeah but
what about your heart
your heart's beating to keep you alive
right well
in a physical sense but i also exist in
a body that doesn't have a heart where
is that body
it's the body you experience in dreams
and i think that this open-minded
body you experience in dreams yeah lucid
dreaming out of body experience so so
when when you become aware
of yourself in a dream state then
you are alive in the dream
state and you are not
conscious your physical form lucid
dreaming your consciousness your but
your physical form is not conscious but
your
your physical form is but your spiritual
tether
is in dream state
and that is what's conscious okay so
then
your heart is still beating though but
could we live so and i think here's the
real question right the reason why i say
no matter how much you know you'll never
know anything
we could evolve to a state of human life
where we don't need our bodies to live
and
this is the i mean to give a
transcendent biology
well to give the the kind of like uh
dystopian example of this i mean
where is where is neo in the matrix yeah
right there
a bunch of humans who believe that
they're alive but they're just living in
a vat
yeah your body's yeah and so
it's one of these exactly so it's one of
these ideas that
when we say that we know i believe that
we actually limit
our ability to engage in research now
can we do some of these
super far out ideas uh in an immediate
context can we execute on those and make
those things real
rapidly no i mean like i said it takes
the evolution of
all to reach that point or the movement
of all to reach a point of evolution
right and so even if you move as one you
can make enough impact as you
you like as one to create the reality
that you envision but it's really the
movement of all that will change that
i really liked what you described about
how
even though someone's moving forward at
a very
quick pace towards divinity let's say or
merging with god
that other people might not be coming as
quickly and that is all
us that is all us and that it is all
it's all up
to us to help raise that vibe
collectively together one
one last thing that i think was really
important that you mentioned yeah um
that we got to before we started
recording which i thought was so
interesting you were talking about this
this uh this feminine and masculine
compassion that exists
yeah and it was funny because when you
said that the fem
the feminine compassion of this like i
love you i love you
i care for you um that that sort of
feeling
and then i was like and then the
masculine one is go execute go build
and you were just like that's right and
i was like wow i can't believe that
that's so funny
uh so unpack that just a little bit more
yeah
so we all embody these aspects of
feminine and masculine compassion and
feminine compassion
is very much nurturing like i've got you
you're safe i love you you're helped
it's very womb-like
and there's a certain thing that has to
do with something about birth
a decent amount uh in in a certain sense
we were talking about
the nature of our relationship to our
capacities
for intuitive intelligence and that
in relation to childbirth yeah and that
why does it seem
like women are more built for these
intuitive capacities and men are more
built for these logical capacities
yeah yeah uh and i think they're yeah i
think there's uh many different reasons
for that and most but most importantly
to touch
to circle back and really touch on what
you said no matter what we think we know
the only thing we'll ever know is that
we'll always be learning
and the only way that we can ever hope
to learn is to accept within ourselves
that what we know is nothing
yes what we know is nothing we can we
can understand something as
law subjectively in a certain space and
in a certain time
in a subjective context but that law is
not an absolute if you're traveling
through the space of the
the cosmos right it's like there's
nothing there's there's not the same
dimension of consistency between these
different levels of our relationship to
existence
but masculine compassion right it's like
at a certain point when the child has
all of this safety
and all this love and all of the
security and all of the nurturing it's
like okay i want to play
i want to play like i'm good i know that
i'm safe here i've had a good time i'm
fed
i'm not hungry my diaper's good i've got
the milk
and the juice box and i'm like ready to
hit the road
mom and dad and then the child wants the
inner child
even wants like direction and action he
wants to do something it wants to
execute it wants to build
and so masculine compassion is the
action oriented it is the go
forth message that nurtures the that
nurtures the growth and that nurtures
the evolution
and really it's that we both have all of
these aspects in ourselves and we've
really had a massive repression a
massive repression of masculine
compassion
um especially in the united states over
the last century
a massive repression masculine
compassion yes
but it does also seem like a lot of the
execution-oriented
tendencies that we have are still
working well you think we've been
executing with compassion we've been
destroying our earth destroying the
planet like we haven't been i'm not
executing
with compassion so that's what's taken a
toll in the last hundred years yeah okay
execute with compassion you guys heard
it here yeah you
you also heard tony lane casterly
teaching us it's always such a pleasure
and it just
it doesn't even feel like we left yeah
for a minute yeah
so interesting yeah yeah it's really
cool
and um yeah whatever whatever time is
and whatever interdimensionality is in
spirits
and unleashing them to their fullest
i'm just in light and dark i'm just i'm
so
i'm like you said the one thing we know
is that we know nothing and that we'll
always keep learning
that was really good okay tony this has
been a blast thank you so much
yeah thank you thank you thank you thank
you
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay thank you everyone as you guys
heard
go and build don't just consume go
create much love everyone
all right peace out